just how successful has industrial
action been over the past 100 years
for nine days in 1926 more than 1.5
million workers went on strike from a
range of different Industries
this was in support of the coal miners
who were fighting for better pay and
working conditions
it was eventually called off by the
trades Union Congress the TUC with the
miners forced to accept the new terms
new laws were later introduced to make
General strikes and so-called
sympathetic strikes illegal foreign
[Music]
ERS went on strike once again but this
time they were more successful the
national Union of Mine Workers called
for a strike at the start of 1972 and
this was overpay
coal mines were shut down causing power
cuts the government even introduced a
three-day week to save electricity
the miners did end up getting a pay rise
of 27 percent
Bart's High inflation eventually wiped
out these gains and the miners felt they
had no choice but to strike once again
strikes led to a defeat in the 1974
election for the Edward Heath government
the labor party eventually took control
with new PM Harold Wilson increasing
miners wages by almost a third
the strikes in the winter of 1978 and 79
are some of the most notable and
consequential in British history
disputes overpay led to mass walkouts
with empty shelves in the supermarkets a
fuel shortage and rubbish on the streets
strikes themselves were largely
successful with many Industries getting
pay Rises but they crucially lost public
support as did the labor government of
the time Margaret Thatcher swept to
power in May 1979. she introduced major
restrictions on Union power
foreign
in the 1980s the miners went on strike
over plans to close 20 pits something
that would have led to 20 000 jobs being
lost
[Applause]
142 000 miners went on strike with the
year-long dispute being dominated by
violent clashes
the Thatcher government refused to budge
and eventually the miners returned to
work with no deal and the pits still
closed
[Music]
these strikes are wrong
for you for the people you serve for the
good of the country
it's the changes we propose that are
right around 2 million public sector
workers went on strike over the
Coalition government's changes to
pensions
it led to 60 percent of schools closing
and thousands of canceled Hospital
operations
it never really gained public support
when the strikes came to an end there
was no real change to the legislation
and then the conservatives in 2015
introduced tougher anti-strike
legislation
the unions are not as strong as they
once were they now have fewer members
less impact on working days lost and
also they're having to contend with even
tougher anti-strike legislation
today Nurses teachers Railway staff and
many more sectors are taking industrial
action as the cost of living crisis
continues
[Music]
[Applause]
some Industries have voted to stop their
industrial action after accepting pay
Rises but with negotiations between the
unions and the governments still ongoing
this new era of mass industrial action
could go well into 2023.